تراجع زخم الاحتجاجات السياسيه في ايران
لتتقدم الاحتجاجات المطلبيه بعد ما دخلت
البلاد في موجه برد وساقع غير مسبوقه خلال
العقود الماضيه لليوم الرابع على التوالي
الاحتجاجات مستمره في محافظات خرسان رضوي
بعد انقطاع الغاز رغم تساقط الثلوج
وانخفاض الحراره الى مدن الصفر وذلك في
بلد يمتلك ثاني اكبر مخزون نصف العالم من
بعد روسيا اما في القهوه التي تضم 80% من
النفط الايراني فاحتج عمال وموظفي
الصناعات النقل على انخفاض روابط رواتبهم
في الوقت الذي تعاني فيه البلاد من ازمه
اقتصاديه خانقه وصل فيها التضخم الى
ثمانيه همم
40% ومن اجل حل ازمه الغاز لجا النظام
الايراني الى التقليل الاستهلاك الغاز
باغلاق المدارس والدوائر في طهران وبعض
المدن الاخرى
السلام عليكم
[تصفيق]
النظام الايراني ان يحصل في الفتره
الماضيه وهو تحول في مسار الاحتجاجات في
البلاد التي بدات تمديدا بمقتل مهسا امين
وبمطالبات بتغيير رموز النظام واس قاطعته
اما الان فقد انحصرت المطالب وباتت تتركز
اكثر على كل ما يتعلق الاقتصاد والمعيشه
اضافه الى انخفاض وتيره الاحتجاجات
وتقلصها نوعا دوليا مشاهدينا طلبه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه كل العالم بضروره الرد
على انتهاكات ايران لحقوق الانسان وفرض
عقوبات ضد النظام الايراني المتهم بانتهاك
المبادئ الاساسيه لحقوق الانسان وتصنيف
الحرس الثوري الايراني كمنظمه ارهابيه
[موسيقى]
سويت شوارع دينك